deep in the sunken depths of earlier'
lies the secret daughter the youngest of
all of the offspring of EDR and Cthulhu
Cthulhu is by far the most valuable of
her father's children but she's a
relatively new addition to mythos being
created by brian lammle and first
appearing in the transition of titus
Crowell a novel first published in 1975
Lumley offered no real description of
Cthulhu but many suggest that her name
may be referenced to the Greek sea
monster Scylla several years later in
1997 the short story titled in his
daughter's darkening womb depicts
Cthulhu is a huge winged octopus
despite Cathal had been quite a recent
addition to the overall mythos
she still has quite an important role to
play Cthulhu himself in his great
hindsight is aware that some time in the
distant future he will be destroyed and
so Casilla became somewhat of a failsafe
plan for when that day does eventually
arrive it has been foretold that Cthulhu
is one day destined to give birth to
Cthulhu
soon after he has been destroyed -
Cthulhu his daughter is essentially
insurance that he will live on
regardless of his fate and this is why
she so heavily guarded by his minions
the deep ones in a young Yara the
Willmar Foundation are an organization
based in the fictional city of Arkham in
Massachusetts they completely dedicate
themselves to combating the great old
ones with hundreds of agents and
connections all around the world when
the head of Cthulhu and what she meant
in the grand scheme of destroying
Cthulhu they launched a mission named
Project X which attempted to kill
Cthulhu were subterranean atomic bomb
the bomb itself being detonated deep in
the ocean would cause humanity little
harm and with Kathy Lagoon the demise of
Cthulhu was only a matter of time the
plan however was unsuccessful they
managed to wound Cthulhu but she was
still able to escape and go back into
hiding with the great dreamer now aware
of humanity's plan to target his
daughter these minions will watch over
her even closer than before
if we take a look at in his daughter's
darling wound Kathina is actually
captured by a group of researchers who
believed her to be a rare undiscovered
species of octopus thinking that she was
the only one of her kind
the research team decided to impregnate
her they also took some notes on her
appearance at first once she is an
enormous six-eyed octopus with small
wings and a red body however they
noticed that she was able to alter her
body proportions at will
she could have large her wings if she
needed to fly and much like a regular
octopus she had eight arms but she was
able to generate more if required and
each of these arms had dozens of
razor-sharp claws at the end of them
Casilla does also appear in Peter relax
in the Hall of the yellow King where she
takes a more human form as a potential
bride to house them despite being a
fairly recent addition to the mythos I
do quite like the role that Cthulhu
plays she's almost a reminder that some
of the great old ones can be slain and
though we cannot comprehend much about
Cthulhu and his personality with Kathina
we can see that he clearly does fear
death enough that he values the
protection of his daughter quite highly
it does also raise an interesting
question if Cthulhu is aware of his own
inevitable death then we as audience
enough wondering what these possible
causes could be having heard my opinion
I'd like to hear what you think is
Cthulhu in addition to the mythos that
you like or would you prefer that she
didn't exist let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
you